will Cloud hiring managers hire me on  the basis of a cloud certification or a  lab training well here's how I like to  think about it the storage can get you  an interview and the hands-on experience  the hard experience will help you  convert that interview into the job and  don't worry about getting too many  serves all you really need is one or two  to demonstrate that you are really  serious about this beyond that  experience counts a lot more sometimes  you might need to spend some time in an  intermediate role like help desk or  customer support or design and for  example when I was starting off I was at  a SAS company as a quality assurance  engineer so no matter where you are find  a path that slowly leads to your ideal  Cloud role